hey f j i good man how's uh how's
everything pretty good yeah You' had a
busy week grinding out content on my way
to uh taking a small amount of time off
for Christmas uh how long you taking off
not you know between Christmas and New
Year's oh that's like a week and even
then if I get interview offers I'll
probably just do it anyway if it's like
a big enough one like I'm always on call
it's hard to say now always on call uh
you just released the well first of all
I watched the first episode of you and
lenis show I didn't finish it I just
assumed it was going to I I just knew I
just knew kit ma like I know where this
is going I knew kit ma wasn't going to
win
yeah it was uh it was it was cool it
felt like some old school like Flavor of
Love type [__] for sure yeah that's what
we were going for but with banging at
the end yeah um how was I only saw a
clip of the scene where you high five
the guy I think we fist
he's a young black dude so I don't know
if he would have been comfortable with
the fullon Eiffel Tower I didn't see cuz
you for people yeah people don't know
there's the Eiffel Tower there's the you
know right so what was it like cuz were
you there with Jason love and L no I
wasn't around for that so what was it
like being in it way better so much
better cuz I felt like this weird little
bit of jealousy when she did this the
scene with Jason love even though I got
over that pretty quick but in terms of
us just shooting like me him and her I
mean I was into it and [__] it didn't
uh I didn't I didn't have any like
conflicted feelings about it it was all
just good times did you have any issues
busting no none did the other guy have
any is was born to come no the guy was
fine yeah we were good cuz I heard the
previous guy had
some I I wasn't there yeah you weren't
there confirmed Jason love he's he's in
his own world too yeah no I can only
imagine that had to be a I don't know
man I don't know if I could do it but I
probably couldn't get hard um yeah I
don't know honestly it took me a couple
of minutes it took you a while normally
I'm hard like on command but it did it
was I'm like kind of tugging on it for
maybe like four or five minutes before
but once it got up it stayed up it
stayed up yeah was was he I didn't see
the video so was he
swinging does he have a big dick you're
saying yeah he's got a pretty good one
him yeah or he is maybe not quite
ajacent love though so not but but more
than you yeah wow yeah you're [__]
you're a sick [__] well I'm not going to
pick a guy smaller than me I swear I
would really I mean smaller dick than me
that's who's coming in here that would
have been so transparent a lot of people
honestly were like oh he picked him
because his dick is smaller than a
couple of the other guys in the
competition not really anything I was
thinking about do does that dude do porn
usually yeah he's a big deal oh he is a
big deal oh yeah he's already popping
yeah oh so you had already kind of seen
was everybody on the show besides kit
map porn saww already there was this
dude churley who's like an internet
comedian I have a feeling that he would
not have actually done the [__] right
couple other people so like rat dick
Ralph the show seemed kind of like
pretty set up obviously it was good the
winner was not determined the wi wasn't
determined people think that we had the
winner picked out the whole time it was
me and her were still kind of going back
and forth about it until the last minute
when we when we had to pick but there
was like there's an interview that we do
at the end of U on episode four the
final episode um we're talking to them
at length and like Lil D's personality
just kind of emerged as being so much
bigger than the other guys that it just
kind of seemed obvious that he would be
the one who kind of was emanating the
most star power and he's been cool about
everything yeah yeah he's super cool cuz
it seems like the the other situation
the guy was like kind of clout chasy a
little bit yeah we definitely talked to
him about that so we could avoid that
mistake like hey if we're going to do
this man yeah don't be a weirdo be a
professional yeah be a pro respect the
marriage how how long how many days did
you guys film it was only two days it
seems like a little longer but two days
quick it's so [__] expensive to have
the whole entire reality crew there that
like and the rent the house exactly did
you guys need to get permits yes oh so
you guys really [__] it's a real
production we hired like a a crazy like
20 person reality crew to film and and
conceptualize the whole thing I've
always told everybody cuz for whatever
reason I've told you this before I I
think people think like we're a lot
closer friends than we are and we're
cool like you're my boy you know like
you've thrown some lobs my way that I
appreciate I don't talk to that many
people in general but people like hit me
up like what's up with your boy he's a
[__] cuck this is weird and I'm like
I don't know dude maybe like and this I
this why I always say you guys have been
[__] women on camera right for so
long uhhuh one dick comes out of left
field and it's like all of a sudden they
just act like you guys aren't sex
workers or performers or whatever you
want to call it like even when we had
our kid I don't really remember like
almost anybody throwing it in our faces
and being like you shouldn't have a kid
you're a porn star y yada whereas now it
feels like every time all you he it's
all people want to do is just tell me
about how I'm like violating the
sanctity of traditional marriage and
like everyone just kind of like
willfully ignores the fact that we do
porn and are let's be honest clearly
trolling slash Hamming it up to get as
much media attention as possible on plug
talk right which worked yeah yeah I
think uh I I mean that clip you guys
sold with the Jason love had to be one
of the more I think you had told me it
was one of the more successful things
ever sold on that platform right the
biggest only fan scene of all time ever
ever seven figures of
course eight figures I I wouldn't want
to take that leap you never know though
in between like around the
five that's a lot dude what do they keep
like I always wonder what is only fan
what's their cut 20% so they're keeping
20% yeah damn so they're eating off he
everybody that's [__] great they're
man only fan that's such a great
business model insane right damn I
remember when they were going to go away
and then all the fake only fans popped
up yeah and we spent like 30 grand to
get a [__] uh plug talk website built
and then by the time it got done only
fans seemed a lot more stable and so we
never even ended up making the website
go live we figured let's just stick to
only fans yeah it's almost like if
YouTube went away you'd have to figure
some [__] out like only fans is kind of
like the new like standard if you're a
content creator even yeah in the porn
industry even know girls like some of
the biggest girls in the industry who
have their own website right at a go and
they just keep it on the back burner
because only fans is just so much more
familiar to the users that it's just
it's a layup like it's just it's just so
much more effective to put your content
on there it's kind of sucks you can't
necessarily like present it exactly the
way that you want to present it like you
would be able to on a website but they
go to your website they got to put in
their credit card information they go to
only fans credit card information is
already in there for like almost
everybody who would ever think about
buying porn right true yeah and it's
kind of like if you're going to go on
YouTube to watch like all your content
why would you go sign up for I mean like
shout out to rumble no D to rumble but
I'm not [__] watching nothing on
Rumble I mean I would if it came down to
it but like if you had to if I had to I
would go to rumble but it would take a
lot yeah it would take a lot especially
like if you got like booted off the
platform or something yeah exactly has
happened with I think what Steve will do
happen happen with him yeah it's it's
good to have a backup but I don't know
um do you guys get to see like uh like
the top earners because we saw the
celebrity top earner of the Year thing
on only fans are you able to see on the
back end like where you rank at the end
of the year they tell you your like
percentage like like you get to see top
00 1% yeah but they don't give you any
more information than that cuz it would
be that would be pretty crazy if we were
able to be like well we make a little
bit more than you and you but not as
much as you that would be cuz I I I feel
like some of these celebrity numbers
have to be inflated I think a lot of
people lie about it and I've like the
bad baby numbers are so [__] insane
yeah I don't know a weird part of me
kind of believes her numbers just
because as ridiculous as that 18 million
month looks it just kind of seemed like
when I when I saw how it went from like
18 million to like 800,000 as the months
went by I was like that seems like a
normal rate of uh you know degrading of
of income but I don't know if you saw
the guy who was like Ruby Rose's number
one I saw you just did interview with
him he said it was cap right yeah and so
I feel like I think he's full of [__] oh
no no no that's that's a funny reaction
that a lot of people keep having to it
is that they think he's actually now
covering up for his own perversion but
let me tell you I've known this guy for
a long time so you know him I I've known
him because he used to be a an assistant
to a tattoo artist who did some work on
me he one time came to the store in like
2018 and he did a a dab with lean
instead of water uh I guess he was just
trying to get some attention doing that
or whatever and the thing about him that
really made me realize it was fake is
well number one one of the top dudes at
only fans corporate told me it was fake
and then after that I realized just that
he knows a lot of the porn star girls
that I know like he was on FaceTime with
Gina Valentina right after our interview
just talking on some regular [__] so
it's like he doesn't seem like the kind
of guy and and also I don't think he has
the kind of money that it would require
well he's supposed to be a crypto whale
I think yeah that's you think that's all
[__] yeah no so cuz he was I saw a
picture he didn't get a ruby tattoo he
did get a Ruby Rose Tattoo I don't know
which is kind of funny cuz I doubt she
would ever want to really see him again
that's very uh that's committing you
want to know something super funny oh my
God I feel bad actually I feel bad even
calling it funny but he had a whole week
of media planned out right he was going
to do Vlad he he he flew to Miami to do
freshman fit immediately after our
interview and he was supposed to go on
that whatever pod we've been dming each
other well there's another one that
probably isn't going to happen I would
assume but like the whatever pod when I
went there yesterday he asked me about
that guy I told him it was fake he goes
oh we're probably just not gonna have
him on then I'm like oh whoops Vlad I
think canceled on him as well fake and
he flew out to do fresh and fit and they
canceled on him why when he after he
already flew out there but I I
understand why because what the [__] are
you interviewing this guy about if it's
all fake yeah especially I mean shout
out to Ruby Rose if this was her team
like hiring some dude it [__] worked
yeah I don't know I mean it's not a bad
idea I told my girl right away as soon
as I saw that I was like we should do
this we should say this some guy give us
100 Grand let's just up the find some
dude hiring some [__] dude that's a
nobody who doesn't have any relationship
no social media presence they made it
seem kind of real with the screenshots
of the oh with the texting and [__] like
weird dude from only fans that was smart
they they and even this right here is
kind of like another round of attention
on Ruby Rose's only fans even if it's
I've noticed too like you'll scroll on
like uh Hollywood unlock and they'll
have these fake stories about like
teacher gets fired from their only fans
account but it's really like we banged
her oh no no but I'm not even talking
about that one cuz that was a real one
yeah there's been so many cuz we talk
about [__] on the radio and my my boy
will be like oh this is uh some some
somebody got fired from their job or
whatever or and then we'll look and'll
be like oh this is a paid ad oh yeah and
now Twitter will add a community note
often times informing the public of oh
this is fake like this account got paid
to post this this is only fan promotion
yeah so shout out to that's a very
useful service right there